there are a large trove of undiscovered
unknown treasures in the National
Geographic image collection from the
early years I'm often asked how many
photographs we have here we have 11.5
million
Edmund we should just one of our guys
staff photographer also was an editor
here and I'm betting that no one in the
art world has ever heard with Edward L
wishard I am sure you're right he like
many of the National Geographic staff
photographers they went out into the
field on different stories decade after
decade this picture you see typical
cobblestone street he's trying to show
this is New Orleans he's trying to show
how New Orleans is is different than
other American cities one of the
features is these remarkable
cobblestones and be as a model working
around in high heels and this model
appears in many many pictures that he
took all over the French Quarter it's
the same model posing in different
settings so that was one of his
techniques and do you think this will
have values to be art well I think these
pictures have a lot of Appeal some of it
is the appeal of nostalgia some of it is
the appeal of this is New Orleans that
people know and want to have a record
I've done in a I think remarkably
remarkably astute photographic manner he
goes beyond New Orleans he goes
throughout the state and he's looking
for typical scenes but he finds
remarkable moments this one was
published also i believe it's about in
this case i'd say a typical old tree
that was on an estate and Richard again
is using models or he's enlisting local
people to be in the picture in this case
to you know add some boyish charm and
also to give the scale of the tree so he
has four little boys sitting on the show
how large it is I know that bonville
Odin is collected in galleries and so
one of the things I was interested in is
how do you thought are valid and
collections stood up against the other
von Louden collections that you've seen
this is the most biggest and most
beautiful nan goldin collection I've
ever seen it had over 100 prints and
many great examples why do you think
people collected some clubs well they
are beautiful pictures of beautiful
young boys and girls they have also a
mythological story that he is hooking
them to but essentially he's just
admiring the Grecian beauty of these
some young people from Sicily these
particular prints just I think have this
kind of a lure this kind of appeal that
you that you that you want this picture
of this girl you want a picture of this
boy it's it's a beautifully composed
printer to print in excellent condition
and look for all those qualities now
over here you have Ponting who I
definitely think as one of the National
Geographic guys because we have so much
to do with Scott and publish so much so
much about the pawn king in Antarctica
Herbert Ponting's work has kind of
gotten out there hazardous well Herbert
hunting has a reputation as a remarkably
strong photographer of explorations in
this case he was traveling with Scott to
the Antarctic and around 1905 1910
period on the exhibition's to discover
this out hole he's definitely in the
photo marketplace and people have
appreciated the extraordinary quality of
his work that one I've seen many times
for sale I've seen it on websites well
it's an iconic image it's an image that
you you know you see it and you don't
forget it it's backlit you have the
shadow of the interior of this ice cave
and then the light shines through the
icicles creating a sense of you know the
coldness and maybe the importance of the
sunlight and then you see the ship as if
it's a little after thought was this a
published image December 1922 page 6 55
there you go
so to have the opportunity to bring them
bring them out and introduce people to
amazing splendors that are in this
collection couldn't be more exciting
there's a lot of images here that have
fabulous artistic value fabulous value
to collectors which we may not have ever
thought of them in that way before and
so we would like to take them out now
and and show them to the world